hey 42 here if you're ever amongst the
30 million tourists that visit the great
city of London every year you won't be
surprised to find that England's capital
offers something for everyone
there's overpriced Pizza in Leicester
Square for the Foodies cruises Down the
River Thames for lovers of water sports
and Buckingham Palace for people who
enjoy sticking their faces through
railings you can even take a guided tour
around some of the palace estate rooms
but if you want to get really up close
and personal with the monarchy you're
better off heading down river to the
Tower of London there you'll be able to
admire the king's ancient crown jewels
and gaze with Wonder upon his
magnificent scepter unfortunately you
won't get the chance to grip his golden
shaft with your own hands because the
crown jewels are underarmed guard by men
dressed as pipe cleaners but that hasn't
stopped people from trying in 1671 an
Irishman by the name of Thomas blood
carried out a ballsy plan to steal the
Sovereign swag over the course of a few
months he nurtured a relationship with
the 77 year old Master of the Jewel
House pretending to be a nobleman and
gradually earning his Trust eventually
the keeper agreed to show blood and his
friends the precious jewels but when
they got inside blood whipped out a
hammer and bonked the keeper nice and
hard on the head then stabbed him a bit
just to be on the safe side but it was
obviously just a flesh wound because the
iron nug and keeper managed to sound the
alarm before blood could escape with the
loot
so he was captured the Irish Rogue was
interrogated by the king himself who
after hearing the whole story did the
natural kingly thing and gave blood a
full pardon plus a large stretch of land
in Ireland to this day nobody's quite
sure why the King was so lenient
but obviously the moral of the story is
if you're brave enough to steal really
really expensive stuff you'll be
handsomely rewarded now go tell your
parents are you tired of spending
precious time preparing meals when you
have a busy schedule especially before
or after a workout I know I am well fuel
complete protein is the world's first
nutritionally complete plant-based
protein powder it's made from
sustainably sourced high quality
animal-free ingredients hemp fiber and
pea protein it's naturally gluten free
and contains more essential amino acids
per gram than whey protein to make a
heel Shake I simply add 300 mL of water
to my heel shaker bottle add a scoop of
fuel complete protein and well give it a
good shake my favorite is this chocolate
fudge brownies flavor I can't believe
this stuff is actually good for me
because it's so rich in chocolatey
honestly it tastes really good I've been
trying a bit better to keep in shape
recently and it's so important after a
workout to fuel upon protein your
muscles need protein to repair
themselves cells and each serving of
fuel contains a massive 20 grams of
plant-based protein 9 grams of essential
amino acids 5 grams of branched chain
amino acids and all with less than 105
calories per serving did I mention it's
also really affordable so click the link
in the description below to try fuel
today if you use my special link you'll
be supporting the channel and with your
first order you'll also receive a free
Shaker a heel t-shirt and a guide to
help you get started a big thanks to
huel for sponsoring this video
the Tower of London has been home to the
Royal gems since the 13th century but
over the course of its long history it's
acted as much more than the world's
biggest jewelry box in 1066 a massive
French bastard called William the
bastard changed his name to William the
Conqueror by conquering England after
which he ordered the construction of the
Tower of London as a way to solidify his
new rule with a giant oppressive
structure the central keep the White
Tower was completed by 1100.
over the following 500 years the tower
acted as a royal residence to many
monarchs including Henry III and Edward
the first but it gains the most infamy
as a prison
some of History's biggest names were
sent to the tower to await their fate
including the future Queen Elizabeth the
First Guy Fawkes Sir Walter rally and
two of Henry V's wives and Berlin and
Lady Jane gray unfortunately for the
last two their stay ended an involuntary
neck removal surgery and in 1941 German
spy Joseph jakobs became the last person
to be executed on Tower grounds the
tower's last ever prisoners oddly enough
were Infamous London gangsters the cray
twins who were sent there in 1952 for
failing to report for national service
across the century the tower played a
crucial role in defending London its
location on the Thames likely to control
access to the city and it served as a
stronghold during conflicts like the
wars of the roses and the English Civil
War but its history doesn't just revolve
around what its walls kept out but also
what they kept in because from the 13th
century to the early 1800s the Tower of
London also functioned as a royal Zoo
now you know that awkward moment when
someone gifts you an apex predator and
you're just not sure where to put it
well in 1235 Holy Roman Emperor
Frederick II said something along the
lines of hold my Mead and then presented
Henry III with free lions who naturally
decided the best place to shove them was
in the Tower of London with all the
prisoners if the fort of free Lions
makes you want to drink lager and kick
things you're probably an English
football fan England's football teams
have worn free lines on their shirts
ever since their very first
International match against Scotland
back in 1872 but the symbol itself can
be traced back 800 years to the Royal
coat of arms of England adopted by the
plantagenic Kings sometime around 1200
A.D so by gifting free lines to the
English crown Frederick II was engaging
in a spot of international ass licking
designed to Curry favor with King Henry
in 1252 Hawk on the fourth king of
Norway made his own bid for the title of
most inappropriate gift in history when
he gave Henry a polar bear which caused
a stir amongst londoners as it was
allowed out of the tower to swim in the
River Thames to hunt for fish
a few years later King Louis IX of
France presented Henry with an elephant
the first to live in England since the
Romans invaded in 43 A.D King Louis had
actually received the Pachyderm from the
Egyptians so it was a bit like handing
off the socks you got for Christmas as a
birthday present to your brother-in-law
but Henry was absolutely delighted by
this hand-me-down elephant and he
ordered the construction of an
absolutely massive bespoke elephant
enclosure yet sadly after only three
years it was dead in fact many of the
towers animals suffered a premature
death these weird and wonderful
creatures from across the globe were
fascinating to look at but nobody in
England had the faintest idea of how to
actually care for them as a result the
animals endured a higher mortality rate
than a red shirt in Star Trek
Henry III may seem like a bit of an
eccentric but it turns out he was only
carrying on a proud family tradition his
ancestor and Son of William the
Conqueror Henry the first had kept a
collection of exotic animals on his
Woodstock estate in Oxfordshire from the
early 1100s via his contacts in foreign
royalty he'd collected an assortment of
animals including camels lions and
porcupines
but his interests were far from
Zoological as a keen Hunter he kept
these beasts alive purely so he could
murder them later and then brag about it
to his mates but thankfully in 1272
Henry stopped murdering the poor
creatures because he too was murdered by
his own body because it died of old age
and so the Woodstock Menagerie was sent
to the Tower of London where the animals
joined a growing congregation around
1290 Edward the first added another Lion
and the links to the mix he even built a
dedicated structure for the Lions which
would later become known cryptically as
the lion Tower and he appointed the
first official Master of the Kings bears
and apes
which to be fair sounds like a much more
believable job title than a lot of the
crap we have today such as Chief
inclusion and diversity officer his
descendant Edward III added a couple of
more Lions they were absolutely mental
for Lions Back Then weren't they they
also loved the odd leopard and later
Kings brought in jackals hyenas and more
in the 15th century all the lions died
and the keeper was understandably sacked
but when the 1600s rolled around under
the reign of James the first British
explorers started pushing deeper into
Africa and began bringing back lions
like they were bottles of duty-free
vodka mostly to supply the horrific lion
baiting sport which was all the rage
back then in case you aren't familiar
lion baiting involves pitting Lions
against dogs in fires to the death now
obviously a lion would easily tear two
shades of out of a dog so to even
the odds the dogs were given
nothing absolutely nothing they all just
died horribly when he wasn't sending
dogs to their deaths James was busy
fleshing out the tower Menagerie with
such exotic Marvels as camels a tiger a
flying squirrel and an Indian Elephant
apparently English elephant care hadn't
Advanced all that much because instead
of water the poor creature was given a
barrel of wine every day between
September and April
apparently the keepers fought a booze
jacket would keep it warm over the
winter it didn't by the early part of
the following Century there were a total
of 11 Lions aligned with various other
cats jackals and birds of prey living in
the tower Sir Christopher Wren that's
the famed architect of Saint Paul's
Cathedral not a knighted bird was even
commissioned to oversee the construction
of a new lion house up until this point
the collection of wild and probably
quite unhappy exotic animals was mostly
kept for the diversion and merriment of
the monarchy you know when they got
bored of pushing gold coins into
prisoners eye sockets or whatever but by
the 18th century the Royal Menagerie was
opened to the public and started to look
like what we might today call a zoo
entry costs three half Pence but if you
couldn't afford the fee no worries all
you had to do was bring along a cat or
dog that could be fed to the Lions
seriously that was actually a thing
in 1811 King George III was gifted a
massive grizzly bear named Martin the
first ever seen in England and soon
afterwards two ostriches were added to
the collection in yet another stroke of
Zoological genius the big birds were fed
on a diet of nails because some 19th
century decided they were able to
digest iron in an incredibly surprising
turn of events one of the ostriches died
it's awful meals proving to be the final
nail in a very long Coffin by 1821 after
centuries of sort of well-meaning But
ultimately Animal Care all that was
left at the Royal Menagerie was good old
Martin and a handful of big cats but the
shockingly short life expectancy of the
animals was about to change with the
appointment of a new keeper Alfred cops
instead of waiting for Rich Aristocrat
and foreign dignitaries to present the
king with animals as gifts something
that was increasingly rare anyway cops
actively sought new creatures to add to
the Menagerie he bought
never-before-seen animals like zebras
alligators and kangaroos to the Tower
and by the time he was done cops had
built up a collection that included some
280 animals from more than 60 species
it was hard work and along the way he
was almost strangled by a hungry bear
constrictor during a public
demonstration but that was far from the
first animal related incident recorded
at the tower in 1686 a Woman by the name
of Mary jenkinson died after being
mauled by a lion and in the 1700s a
young sailor was killed when a baboon
for a cannonball at his head but in 1830
things really kicked off a man was
attacked by a leopard a monkey bit
another man's leg and the Wolf escaped
never to be seen again
it was fast becoming clear that the
Royal Menagerie was becoming a royal
pain in the ass and around this time a
decision was made to move all of the
animals to Regents Park where the
Zoological Society of London had
established what is today known as
London Zoo by 1835 the only furry things
left at the Tower of London were the
guards headgear
it was the end of a 600-year era but it
must have been quite a relief for the
animals who by then would probably
rather tired of maltreatment
malnutrition and death in the almost 200
years since Animal Welfare has continued
to improve and while zoos are still
controversial in the eyes of many at
least we no longer serve the elephants
buckets of merlot
thanks for watching